bonsoir
mille milliards de dollars américains
pour une Vidia est-ce que ça vaut ça la
société continue de poursuivre ça qu'on
se croissance ça va justifier ce type
d'évaluation là le prochain trimestre la
société va publier selon ses projections
des ventes de 11 milliards de dollars on
sera il y a 3 ans la compagnie avait ce
chiffre d'affaires-là annuellement donc
cela compagnie garde cette cadence là
dans qu'on vient de mentionner sur une
période de 12 mois la compagnie se
négocie au prix d'aujourd'hui environ à
20 fois c'est vente ce qui est à peu
près sa moyenne historique donc on est
dans une trajectoire normale la finance
ce que vous me dites là c'est que
l'évolution financière suit son
évaluation boursière ou vice-versa il y
a un optimisme dans le secteur si la
société livre ses résultats livres la
marchandise comme en lien avec ces
projections je pense que l'évaluation
peut être considérée par contre faut se
rappeler que Wall Street pour être
brutal c'est la compagnie rencontre pas
ses attentes dans les 12 prochains mois
les annoncer à chaque trimestre
évidemment on peut voir de la volatilité
dans le secteur en particulier dans le
titre de Nvidia mais qu'est-ce qui fait
que Nvidia devient cette entreprise
phare dans le secteur des processeurs
graphiques puces pour l'intelligence
artificielle mais son fondateur
iPhone puis je m'explique c'est depuis
40 ans on a eu des grands moments
l'ordinateur personnel l'arrivée de
l'Internet puis il a été le téléphone
intelligent à partir de là c'est une
plateforme sur lequel on a vu plein
d'applications qui ont été créées on
parle à Airbnb on peut penser à
uber aujourd'hui l'intelligence
artificielle générative c'est une
plateforme négative ou exactement donc
c'est une plateforme qui va faire des
calculs énormes sur une grande base de
données il faut faire une synthèse entre
autres linguistiques on parlait de chat
GPT ça peut être dans le visuel si on
veut créer des images puis même au
niveau des développeurs on disait nos
enfants doivent coder mais aujourd'hui
on va pouvoir faire des requêtes puis un
code va se créer pour nous donc cette
plateforme là ça va créer nouveau
secteur d'activité puis on est juste au
début de cette tendance alors le PDG de
Nvidia se nomme Johnson Wang il était à
Taiwan en fin de semaine pour dévoiler
justement des nouveaux produits des
services liés à l'intelligence
artificielle quand on parle
d'intelligence artificielle générative
comme étant la prochaine grande
révolution ça veut dire quoi ça le
génératif là mais c'est ça c'est que
maintenant ça va être un outil qui peut
nous accompagner pour justement
développer nous rendre faire des gains
de productivité entre autres comme je
mentionnais aujourd'hui on voit dans
linguistique dans le visuel dans le
développement de logiciel puis
probablement on va voir d'autres
applications des prochaines années en
quoi les puces parce qu'on sait que les
puces sont partout dans les appareils
électroniques en grande partie pourquoi
les puces sont si importantes dans
l'intelligence artificielle mais le
traitement de données est significatif
donc on a besoin de plus oui mais de
plus très performante et là en ce moment
de calcul accélérés donc en ce moment
cette compagnie d'un avantage conc
essentiel elle a vraiment un avance
parce que à le la technologie elle a la
capacité de production donc on vient de
voir depuis quelques mois le potentiel
entre autres avec chat GPT dans le
linguistique donc il y a beaucoup
d'entreprises qui veulent investir pour
développer leur propre technologie ou
développer sur les plateformes qui
existent comme ça de Open et high qui
est derrière chat gipity et là il y a
une demande donc la question c'est
est-ce que les concurrents vont pouvoir
innover avec la création de produits il
y a certains fabricants de
semi-conducteurs qui sont dans la course
on entend parler que alphabet puis
mettait aussi développe leur propre
processeur pour pour rivaliser mais ils
n'ont pas la même capacité de production
mais Nvidia si je me trompe pas c'est
80% des processeurs graphiques pour
l'intelligence artificielle en ce moment
le système de open c'est des milliers de
processeurs graphiques de Nvidia je
lisais un article récemment et lendemain
ce que veut initier une stratégie puis
il y a commandé les mêmes types de
processeurs donc actuellement il y a une
demande spécifique pour ce type ce qui
pourrait y avoir une forme de monopole
qui pourrait se créer comme on a vu par
exemple pour Amazon qui rapidement
est devenu tellement dominante dans son
secteur ouais Amazon en particulier il y
a une initiative dans l'Info nuage AWS
ils ont créé le cette innovation là puis
on a environ 6 ans d'avance dans le
secteur d'activité là donc c'est sûr que
ils ont gagné une part de marché
aujourd'hui par contre il y a des
nouveaux concurrents on voit cette
avantage-là c'était rodé donc à court
terme c'est clair qu'il y a une visite
un avantage concurrentiel mais moi je
convaincu qu'il y a beaucoup
d'investissements massifs en recherche
et développement on voit des grandes
compagnies de technologie qui ont la
capacité d'investir qui vont essayer
justement de rétrécir cet accord-là avec
l'essor des crypto monnaie avec les
puces dans les jeux vidéo puis là
aujourd'hui l'intelligence artificielle
est-ce que Nvidia est déjà un acteur
technologique de premier plan est-ce
qu'on comme Google comme Microsoft ouais
je pense qu'on connaît moins la société
parce qu'en tant que consommateur les
gens connaissent moins se produit là
mais définitivement la trajectoire
qu'elle a son modèle d'affaires est
liberté pour les prochaines années
effectivement donc de plus en plus on va
entendre parler de cette entreprise là
est-ce qu'il y a une bulle de
l'intelligence artificielle est-ce que
c'est possible qu'il y a une bulle
autour de cela compte tenu de la
frénésie actuelle c'est clair que les
attentes sont élevées puis dans
différents secteurs d'activité quand on
voit entre la conception d'une déplacé
et là il peut avoir des déceptions donc
c'est pour ça que je peux dire qu'il
pourra probablement avoir justement des
enjeux au niveau des attentes de Wall
Street par rapport aux résultats à
l'exécution cependant il y a un grand
nombre d'entreprises qui qui développe
l'intelligence artificielle mais je
crois qu'il y a aussi une entreprise
traditionnelles comme lui adopté une
stratégie numérique qui aujourd'hui
voudront implanter une stratégie
d'intelligence artificielle pour faire
des gains de productivité pour les
entreprises améliorer l'expérience du
consommateur donc je pense au secteur-là
par contre si on est patients on va voir
vraiment des développements dans la
prochaine décennies intéressantes si mon
plan très intéressant merci merci
beaucoup pour voir nos émissions en
entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]